This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. New Yorkers are known to disagree about a lot of things. Who's got the best pizza? What's the fastest subway route? Yankees or Mets? But I would bet that if you pulled every New Yorker, all 8,500,000 of them,
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。纽约人出了名地在很多事情上意见不一。谁家的披萨最好吃？哪条地铁路线最快？洋基队还是大都会队？但我敢打赌，如果你随机调查每一个纽约人，全部 8,500,000 人，
they would agree on one thing. Pennst Socks! That's Ann Heperman, our friend and reporter in New York who also hates Penn Station. There is nothing joyful about Penn Station. It's windowless, airless, crowded, 650,000 people have to suffer through it on their daily commute. That's more traffic than the region's three airports combined. Luckily though, I'm not one of them. We're in Penn Station now. We tagged along with our unlucky friend, Jonathan
他们会在一件事上达成一致。宾州车站太烂了！那是安·赫珀曼，我们在纽约的朋友兼记者，她也讨厌宾州车站。宾州车站没有任何让人高兴的地方。它没有窗户，不通风，拥挤不堪，65,000人每天通勤都得受它的罪。这比该地区三个机场加起来的客流量还要多。不过幸运的是，我不是其中之一。我们现在就在宾州车站。我们跟着我们倒霉的朋友乔纳森
Minhevar. He's a producer for this American life and commutes from his home in Jersey to Penn Station. His experience of Penn Station is like being at a Black Friday sale at Walmart every day, always. Like the whole time people are pushing you, squeezing through a tiny stairway to get down to the tracks. It's the only place in which people are actually touching your ass and you're not supposed to say anything about it. The air is often hot and stuffy.
明赫瓦尔一起逛了逛。他是《This American Life》的一名制作人，从他位于泽西的家通勤到宾州车站。他对宾州车站的体验就像每天都在沃尔玛的黑色星期五大促现场一样，而且天天如此。就像全程都有人在推搡你，从一个狭小的楼梯挤着下到站台。这是唯一一个人们真的在摸你的屁股，而你却不能说任何话的地方。这里的空气常常闷热。
It feels like whatever wizard of Oz is behind, like that they are just watching in their little tower and watching, like, oh look at them crush each other, look at them want to eat each other. It's awful. It's awful. And it's my best way to get home every day. Poor guy.
感觉就像无论哪个绿野仙踪里的巫师藏在后面，比如他们只是在自己的小塔里看着，看着，哦看他们互相压榨，看他们恨不得把对方吃掉。太糟糕了。太糟糕了。而这是我每天回家最好的方式。真可怜这家伙。
And you can also see some Penn station hate in popular culture about New York, like in this episode of Broad City, where one character Abby gets dumped because her boyfriend would rather end a relationship than take a train out of Penn Station. Penn Station, I can't. It's disgusting. It's kind of a deal breaker for me.
你还可以在流行文化中看到对纽约宾州车站的厌恶，比如在《大城小妞》的这一集中，其中一个角色艾比被甩了，因为她的男友宁愿结束一段恋情，也不愿坐火车离开宾州车站。宾州车站，我受够了。太恶心了。对我来说这简直是不可接受的底线。
But here's the worst thing about Penn Station. This drab, low ceiling, uninspiring, unexceptional building was once the opposite of all of those things. With a vast space, I mean the building itself was the fourth largest building in the world when it was finished. That's Jill Jones describing the original Penn Station. She wrote a great book about it, called Conquering Gotham. The original Penn station in New York City opened in 1910. It was majestic.
但宾州车站最糟糕的地方在于。这座单调、低矮、毫无灵感、平庸的建筑，曾经是所有这些的反面。它有着广阔的空间，我是说，这座建筑在完工时本身是世界上第四大建筑。那是吉尔·琼斯对最初的宾州车站的描述。她写了一本关于它的优秀书籍，名叫《征服哥谭》。纽约市最初的宾州车站于 1910 年开业。它宏伟壮丽。
Imagine the Parthenon, but for trains. The facade was a line of massive Doric columns. You'd walk through them to send down a grand staircase and into a waiting room designed to remind you of a Roman temple. With these very high ceilings and very spectacular light coming through, and that ushered you into all of these staircases that took you down into the train tracks. And the guy behind all of this was Alexander Cassatt, the head of Pennsylvania Railroad. With the original Penn Station, Cassatt was fixing a problem that had plagued New York for years. Namely, it was a complete pain in the ass to get from New Jersey to Manhattan.
想象一下帕特农神庙，不过是为火车站建的。它的正面是一排巨大的多立克柱。你穿过这些柱子，走下一座宏伟的楼梯，进入一个旨在让你想起罗马神庙的候车室。这里有非常高的天花板，耀眼的光线倾泻而下，把你引入所有通往火车站台的楼梯。而这一切背后的男人是宾夕法尼亚铁路公司的负责人亚历山大·卡萨特。通过最初的宾州车站，卡萨特解决了一个多年来一直困扰纽约的问题。也就是说，从新泽西到曼哈顿简直是个天大的麻烦。
People commuting from Jersey had to schlep across the Hudson River on a slow ferry. So Cassatt built the first-ever train tunnel to run under the Hudson River. It was considered one of the greatest engineering feats ever. I know we say that all the time, but we really mean it this time. And Cassatt built Penn Station Terminal to crown his monumental achievement. The architecture celebrated both the past and the future. It was a combination of this very ancient grandeur and this extremely industrialized form of transportation. These really powerful trains.
从泽西通勤的人们不得不坐着慢吞吞的渡轮艰难地穿过哈德逊河。因此，卡萨特修建了有史以来第一条穿过哈德逊河底的铁路隧道。这被认为是历史上最伟大的工程壮举之一。我知道我们经常这么说，但这次我们是认真的。卡萨特建造了宾州车站航站楼来为他这座不朽的成就加冕。这种建筑风格既赞美了过去，又歌颂了未来。它是这种极其古老的宏伟与这种高度工业化的运输形式的结合。这些威力巨大的火车。
Newspapers called Penn Station the eighth wonder of the world. People call a lot of things the eighth wonder of the world that we really mean at this time. Everyone loved it. Everyone that is except for what other railroad family that owned a little station right across town. This then made the existing Grand Central Station, which was owned by the Vanderbilt family, look really shabby. At the time when the original Penn Station was built, Grand Central Station was not anywhere near as grand as it is now. But the Vanderbilt just couldn't be outdone by this other train station. Clearly, how embarrassing. So in Grand Central needed a little touch-up.
报纸称宾州车站为世界第八大奇迹。人们把很多东西都称为世界第八大奇迹，而这次我们是认真的。每个人都喜欢它。除了另一家铁路家族之外，每个人都喜欢它，他们在城另一头拥有一座小车站。这使得范德比尔特家族拥有的现有中央车站看起来非常寒酸。在最初的宾州车站建成时，中央车站远没有现在这么宏伟。但范德比尔特家族就是不能被另一个火车站比下去。显然，这太尴尬了。所以中央车站需要一点修饰。
The Vanderbilt decided to tear it down and build a newer, shinier, grander, grand central station. The one we know today. So there was this very early connection between the two. So Penn Station and Grand Central started out as enemies but as the years passed they were like the last two drunks at the party trying to keep the night from coming to an end. The country was in a very different sort of mindset that new was good and flying was good and cars were
范德比尔特家族决定把它拆掉，建造一个更新、更闪亮、更宏伟的中央车站。也就是我们今天所知道的那座。因此，这两者之间有着非常早期的联系。所以宾州车站和中央车站最初是死敌，但随着岁月的流逝，它们就像派对上最后两个醉鬼，试图阻止夜晚走向终点。当时全国的心态非常不同，人们觉得新的好，飞的好，汽车好，
good and trains were bad. Penn station was only 40 years old at this point but already its days were numbered. After World War II, passenger trains just weren't as popular anymore. Pennsylvania Railroad was just leading money. The company couldn't afford the upkeep of Penn station's grander. Everything that had been glorious about it
火车不好。到这个时候，宾州车站只有 40 岁，但它的日子已经屈指可数了。二战后，客运列车不再那么受欢迎了。宾夕法尼亚铁路公司一直在亏钱。公司无力承担宾州车站宏伟气派的维护费用。所有曾经令它辉煌的事物
really got sort of covered with grime and it was dirty and they didn't fix the broken windows and there are all these pigeons flying around. It's really hard to wash pigeon poop off a forestry arch-class ceiling. So people did not feel that this was this glorious place, they felt it was really crummy. For a lot of people, Penn Station had become a money-sucking albatross of a station that also sat on nine acres of precious midtown Manhattan real estate. Remember this is New York City. Real estate in New York is in the airspace.
真的有点被污垢覆盖了，它很脏，他们不修破损的窗户，到处都有鸽子飞来飞去。要把鸽子屎从带森林装饰的拱形玻璃天花板上洗掉可真难。所以人们并不觉得这是一个辉煌的地方，他们觉得它真的很逊。对很多人来说，宾州车站已经信誉扫地，成了一个吸金的累赘，而且它还占据着曼哈顿中城九英亩宝贵的房地产。记住，这是纽约市。纽约的房地产就贵在空域权上。
Pennsylvania railroad executives knew that they could make tons of money if they could rent out the space above the station to a big tall building. There were proposals to build a parking garage, amphitheaters, a 40-story office tower. But the one that won out was the futuristic sports and entertainment palace known as Madison Square Garden. The deal that Pennsylvania Railroad cut with the developer Irving Felt was to keep the tracks below Penn Station and sell the rights to the airspace on top. And blow up Penn Station in the process. Here's where I wish we could say that the whole city banded together to save the station,
宾夕法尼亚铁路公司的管理人员知道，如果他们能把车站上方的空间租给一栋高大大楼，他们就能赚大钱。当时有建造停车场、露天剧场、40层办公楼的提案。但胜出的方案是被称为麦迪逊广场花园的未来主义体育娱乐宫殿。宾夕法尼亚铁路公司与开发商欧文·费尔特达成的交易是保留宾州车站下方的轨道，并出售顶部屋顶空域权。并在过程中炸毁宾州车站。这里我希望我们可以说整个城市联合起来拯救这座车站，
but actually no one really cared, except for a small group of activist architects. Agbany, the action group for better architecture in New York. Agbany, it's a terrible acronym, but definitely a cause I can support. Peter Sampton was one of those architects. I went over to his house on the Upper West Side, and we looked through old photographs from the only march to save Penn Station.
但实际上根本没人关心，除了少数激进的建筑师。Agbany，纽约更好的建筑行动小组。Agbany，这是一个糟糕的首字母缩略词，但绝对是一个我能支持的事业。彼得·萨姆普顿就是那些建筑师之一。我去了他在上西区的家，我们翻看了拯救宾州车站的唯一一次游行中的老照片。
It is me. I think this was my sign right here that said, don't sell our city short. The date was August 2, 1962. There were 200 rowdy architects. We would have to wear respectable clothing, because otherwise they wouldn't take us seriously. Just kidding about the rowdy part. These were architects. The men wore suits.
这是我。我想这正是我当时举的牌子，上面写着：不要低估我们的城市。日期是 1962 年 8 月 2 日。有 200 名吵闹的建筑师。我们不得不穿着得体的衣服，因为否则他们不会认真对待我们。开个关于吵闹的玩笑。这些可是建筑师。男人们穿着西装。
The women wore white gloves and pearls. We each sort of prided ourselves on doing better lettering than the next sign. They marched up and down 7th Avenue, shouting, Polish don't demolish, save our heritage, things like that is what we would say. I mean, keep in mind, none of us were ever in a picket line before. You don't say. Still, the protest made the front page of the New York Times. Architects fight Penn Station plan.
女人们戴着白手套和珍珠项链。我们每个人都以比下一个标语写得更好的字体而自豪。他们在第七大道上游行，高喊着：“抛光，不要拆毁”、“拯救我们的遗产”，诸如此类的话就是我们会喊的。我的意思是，请记住，我们以前从来没有人参加过纠察队。真不敢相信。尽管如此，这场抗议还是登上了《纽约时报》的头版。建筑师反对宾州车站计划。
But it was too late. On October 28, 1963, at 9am, Jackhammer's torrent to Penn Station's granite slabs. The demolition took a long time, about three years. You know, it was like a great animal because you'd sort of a black of the outside and then you saw the inside which was all this beautiful pink, so it was like the flesh was opened up with a knife. And after three years most of the original Penn stations remains the door column, the granite and travertine details, all of that had been dumped into a
但为时已晚。1963 年 10 月 28 日上午 9 点，风镐轰鸣着砸向宾州车站的花岗岩板。拆除工作花了很长时间，大约三年。你知道，它就像一头巨大的动物，因为你先看到外面被封住，然后你看到了里面，全都是美丽的粉红色，所以它就像是用刀剖开了血肉。三年后，最初的宾州车站的大部分遗迹——门柱、花岗岩和石灰华细节——都被倾倒进了
New Jersey swamp. And of course they gave us a new Penn station, one that was summarily hated by everyone. In 1968, architectural historian Vincent Scully famously remarked that, whereas before, one entered the city like a god. One's skulls in now, like a rat. After the destruction of Penn station, Mayor Robert Wagner created the first landmarks preservation commission.
新泽西州的沼泽里。当然，他们给了我们一个新的宾州车站，一个遭到所有人一致厌恶的车站。1968 年，建筑历史学家文森特·斯库利曾有一句名言：“以前，人们像神一样进入这座城市。而现在，人们像老鼠一样钻进来。”宾州车站被毁后，罗伯特·瓦格纳市长创建了第一个地标保护委员会。
In 1965, the group helped pass the city's first-ever landmarks law so that something is drastic as the destruction of Penn Station could never happen again. But the landmark laws were flawed. It was a joke. New Yorkers are so blunt. That's Roberta Gratz. She wrote award-winning stories about the problems with the city's landmark laws for the New York Post are so blunt. That's Roberta Gratz. She wrote award-winning stories about the problems with the city's landmark laws for the New York Post in the 1970s. For those of you who are
1965 年，该组织帮助通过了该市历史上第一部地标法，这样像摧毁宾州车站这样激烈的事件就永远不会再次发生。但地标法是有缺陷的。这简直是个笑话。纽约人说话就是这么直白。那是罗伯塔·格拉茨。她为《纽约邮报》撰写了关于该市地标法问题的获奖报道，说话就是这么直白。那是罗伯塔·格拉茨。她在 20 世纪 70 年代为《纽约邮报》撰写了关于该市地标法问题的获奖报道。对于你们中那些
too young to know that the New York Post used to be a really good newspaper. There were a number of problems with the landmark laws. The biggest one though was that the landmarks commission didn't meet all that much. They met for six months every three years. So if you missed your window to get your favorite New York City building landmark, tough luck. And in the meantime, the bulldozer operated at will. Grat says a lot of buildings were lost even after the landmark laws were passed, like the singer building, which was once the tallest building in the world, and the old metropolitan opera house, and the Astor Hotel. And then in 1968, Penn Station's old rival Grand Central Station was poised to be yet another
太年轻而不知道《纽约邮报》曾经是一份非常好的报纸的人来说。地标法存在许多问题。不过最大的问题是地标委员会开会并不那么频繁。他们每三年开会六个月。所以如果你错过了为你最喜欢的纽约市建筑争取地标身份的时机，那就只能自求多福了。与此同时，推土机随心所欲地运作。格拉茨说，即使在地标法通过后，许多建筑还是被拆毁了，比如曾经是世界最高建筑的胜家大楼、旧大都会歌剧院和阿斯特酒店。然后在 1968 年，宾州车站的老对手中央车站也面临着变成又一个
pile of rubble. Here in the cathedral like faces of the terminal itself robbing hot of a nation's little trouble. We have a life. I love Grand Central Station. Hands down it is my favorite place in the city. Welcome to Grand Central Terminal. Kent Barrowick is just as excited as I am to be here.
废墟堆的危险。在这里，在航站楼大教堂般的立面中，摆脱了一个国家的微小烦恼。我们有生活。我爱中央车站。毫无疑问，这是我在这个城市最喜欢的地方。欢迎来到中央车站。肯·巴里克和我一样兴奋能来到这里。
He's been involved in saving New York City's historic buildings for decades. We're standing under Grand Central's beautiful, vaulted green ceiling, which is decorated with constellations. I just love looking up at it. You and every other person. Let's see if we can find anybody doing this rare to community without finding somebody, taking a picture or what was one where she's just about to take a picture. Grand Central feels like a throwback to what I feel like the old Penn station must have been like.
几十年来，他一直致力于拯救纽约市的历史建筑。我们站在中央车站美丽、拱形的绿色天花板下，天花板上装饰着星座。我就是喜欢抬头看着它。你和所有其他人一样。让我们看看能不能找到任何人在这里一边Commute，一边发现有人在拍照，或者刚好有一个人正准备拍照。中央车站让人觉得像是回到了我心目中老宾州车站当年的样子。
Just like the original Penn station, Grand Central was a hard building to keep clean. Kent Barwick points to a small patch of black in the far corner of the ceiling. Just to the left of there there seems to be a piece of journey limestone and a piece of journey ceiling. I think that's the shows what the ceiling was like, which was essentially nicotine coated. I was from there, everybody smoked all the time. That black ceiling square was left on purpose to remind people what Grand Central was like back in the day.
就像最初的宾州车站一样，中央车站也是一栋很难保持干净的建筑。肯·巴里克指着天花板远角的一小块黑色斑块。就在那里的左边，似乎有一块陈年石灰石和一块陈年天花板。我认为这展示了天花板以前的样子，基本上是被尼古丁覆盖的。就是从那时候开始的，每个人都在抽烟。特意留下了那个黑色的天花板方块，是为了提醒人们中央车站过去的模样。
In the 1960s, Grand Central's history was almost a carbon copy of pen stations. They were losing money because the building was so expensive to maintain, and fewer people were taking trains. Just like Penn station. Railroad executives decided they needed to sell the airspace on top of the station and invite developers to build. Saying hey, wouldn't a 55-story office tower be nice on top of this, baby? Which would demolish Grand Central's facade and most of its interior. But here's where the story of Grand Central and Penn Station diverge.
在 20 世纪 60 年代，中央车站的历史几乎是宾州车站的翻版。它们都在亏钱，因为这栋建筑维护成本太高，而且坐火车的人越来越少。就像宾州车站一样。铁路高管们决定，他们需要出售车站顶部的空域权，并邀请开发商进行建设。他们说，嘿，在这个宝贝顶上建一栋 55 层的办公楼不是挺好的吗？这将摧毁中央车站的正面及其大部分内部结构。但这就是中央车站和宾州车站的故事分道扬镳的地方。
Remember those landmark laws that happened in the years after the original Penn Station was demolished? Well, as weak as they were, they did manage to get Grand Central designated as a landmark. So the city denies the railroad executives' plans. The owners of Grand Central were not placed. They wanted the money they were going to get from selling their air rights, the space above Grand Central, so they sued the city. The case was a long one. It went on for nearly a decade.
还记得在最初的宾州车站被拆除后几年出台的那些地标法吗？好吧，尽管它们很薄弱，但它们确实成功地将中央车站指定为了地标。因此，市政府拒绝了铁路高管的计划。中央车站的所有者很不高兴。他们想要通过出售他们的空中权（中央车站上方的空间）获得的资金，所以他们起诉了市政府。这场官司打得很久。持续了近十年。
And it was a bit of a nail-biter. Grand Central nearly lost in 1975 when a state judge ruled against the city's designation of it as a landmark. The new mayor, Abe Beam, almost didn't appeal the ruling, saying against the city's designation of it as a landmark. The new mayor, Abe Beam, almost in appeal to the ruling, saying that the city was poised to lose millions in court costs. So Kent Barwick and others created the committee to save Grand Central. With one member who was a bit of a game changer. I think if there is a great effort, even if it's at the 11th hour, you can succeed.
而且这有点让人提心吊胆。1975 年，当一名州法官裁定反对市政府将其指定为地标时，中央车站差点就输了。新市长亚伯·比姆差点没有对这一裁决提起上诉，说反对市政府将其指定为地标。新市长亚伯·比姆差点没有对这一裁决提起上诉，说市政府将在诉讼费上损失数百万美元。于是肯·巴里克和其他人创建了拯救中央车站委员会。其中有一位成员简直是个能扭转乾坤的关键人物。我认为如果付出巨大努力，即使是在最后一刻，你也能成功。
And I know that that's what we'll do. Enter Jacqueline Kennedy-O-Nasses. Thank you. Kennedy-O-Nasses fronted a save grand central press conference held in 1975 by the Municipal Arts Society. Kent Barwick was at that press conference. He says that with Jackie O. so prominently involved, the fight went from a New York battle to a national one. And people began to write in, you know,
而且我知道这正是我们会做到的。杰奎琳·肯尼迪·奥纳西斯登场了。谢谢。肯尼迪·奥纳西斯在 1975 年由市政艺术协会举办的拯救中央车站新闻发布会上露面。肯·巴里克参加了那场新闻发布会。他说，由于杰基·奥的显赫参与，这场斗争从一场纽约的战役变成了一场全国性的战役。人们开始写信来，你知道的，
because Iowa had a $5 dollar bill enclosed. The case went all the way to the Supreme Court. And on June 26, 1978, the highest court in the land ruled in favor of New York City's landmark laws. Just as William Brennan wrote of Grand Central's architecture, quote, such examples are not so plentiful in New York City that we can afford to lose any of the few we have. And we must preserve them in a meaningful way. In other words, Grand Central would not suffer the same fate as its old friend and foe, Penn
因为爱荷华州有人随信寄来了五美元钞票。案件一直打到了最高法院。1978 年 6 月 26 日，国家最高法院做出有利于纽约市地标法的裁决。正如威廉·布伦南在谈到中央车站的建筑时写道，引述：“这样的例子在纽约市并不多，以至于我们经得起失去我们仅有的几个例子的代价。我们必须以一种有意义的方式保护它们。”换句话说，中央车站不会遭受与其老朋友兼死敌宾州车站相同的命运。
Station. So the landmark laws, with a lot of help from Jack-Yo-Nasses, squeaked out of wind, and all of these years later, one of the ways people comfort themselves about the loss of the original Penn Station is with this idea that the laws that came out of the destruction of Penn Station saved Grand Central. So you know it's okay because it died for cause. I don't think Grand Central would have been saved without Penn Station. Penn Station sacrificed itself so that Grand Central could live.
所以，在地标法以及杰基·奥纳西斯的巨大帮助下，险险赢得了一场胜利。多年后的今天，人们在为失去最初的宾州车站而感到安慰时，采用的想法之一就是：正是宾州车站的摧毁所诞生的法律拯救了中央车站。所以你知道没关系，因为它死得其所。我认为如果没有宾州车站，中央车站就不会被拯救。宾州车站牺牲了自己，好让中央车站得以存活。
That was Peter Sampton. You heard from him earlier. He was one of the architects that fought and failed to save Penn Station. But the tie between the destruction of Penn Station and the saving of Grand Central is actually kind of tenuous. For Roberta Gratz, it was Jackie O. Not the landmark laws that saved Grand Central. It's all very romantic to assume that the demolition of something so historic as Penn Station would have precipitated a strong landmarks law. It just isn't true. A sacrificial land like Penn Station can only do so much. People have to actually fight and win like they did with Grand Central for laws to have
那是彼得·萨姆普顿。你刚才听过他的发言。他是当年为拯救宾州车站而战却最终失败的建筑师之一。但宾州车站的毁灭与中央车站的获救之间的联系其实有点脆弱。对罗伯塔·格拉茨来说，是杰基·奥，而不是地标法拯救了中央车站。认为拆除像宾州车站这样具有历史意义的东西会促成一项强有力的地标法，这实在是太浪漫了。事实并非如此。像宾州车站这样的牺牲品作用有限。人们必须像在中央车站这件事上那样真正去战斗并赢得胜利，法律才能真正发挥作用
teeth. Roberta Gratz was actually one of those people. The reporting she did on the landmarks commission is just one of the things that led to the landmark laws ultimately being strengthened. And of course, the Supreme Court upholding those laws in the grand central case set an important precedent for saving future landmarks.
有威慑力。罗伯塔·格拉茨其实就是那些人之一。她对地标委员会的报道只是最终促使地标法得到加强的事情之一。当然，最高法院在中央车站案中维持这些法律的判决，为拯救未来的地标设定了重要的先例。
These days, it's still a fight to save a building. But the laws are there, and they're stronger now than they once were. So if you're a beautiful old building in New York, you don't have to rely on a celebrity endorsement or a rag tag group of architect activists chanting, We'll be with you live and something to turn by. PMTA, please. Thank you for your cooperation. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Ann Heverman. Thanks to the WNYC Archives and Julia Barton for her help in editing. 99% Invisible is Sam Greenspan, Katie Mingle, Avery Trouffleman, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 Local public radio KALW in San Francisco and produced at the offices
如今，拯救一栋建筑仍然是一场斗争。但法律就在那里，而且比以前更强大了。所以如果你是纽约一栋美丽的旧建筑，你就不必依赖名人的背书或者一群衣衫褴褛、高喊着“我们将为您现场直播，某某要转台了”的建筑师激进分子。PMTA，拜托了。感谢您的配合。本周的 99% Invisible 由安·赫珀曼制作。感谢 WNYC 档案库以及朱莉娅·巴顿在编辑方面提供的帮助。99% Invisible 的成员有萨姆·格林斯潘、凯蒂·明格尔、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼，以及我罗曼·马斯。我们是旧金山 91.7 本地公共广播电台 KALW 的一个项目，制作地点位于加利福尼亚州美丽奥克兰市中心
of Arxine, an architecture and interiors firm in beautiful, downtown Oakland, California. You can find the show and hang out with other people who like the show on Facebook. All of us are fascinating on Twitter. The search for 99% of visible and you can find us and follow us, we have a great Tumblr but you're always welcome at our place at 99pi.org. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
一家名为 Arxine 的建筑与室内设计公司的办公室里。您可以在 Facebook 上找到这个节目，并与其他喜欢这个节目的人一起交流。我们在 Twitter 上都很有吸引力。搜索 99% Invisible 就能找到并关注我们，我们有一个很棒的 Tumblr，但随时欢迎您来到我们在 99pi.org 的大本营。来自 PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。